image recognition techniques play a
vital role in multiple domains ranging
from a simple science project to a
complex multi-million dollar space
project
today the space centers are investing
billions of dollars into space
exploration also spacex is actively
planning for space colonization
artificial intelligence and image
recognition skills play a monumental
role in bringing these projects to
reality
this potential requirement opens up
lucrative career opportunities in the
world of data science and artificial
intelligence
if you are the one who is keen about
communicating to artificial intelligence
and enhancing its skill set in various
areas then skillup's complete artificial
intelligence and image recognition
certification program is just what you
need to upskill and get ahead this
course is curated in collaboration with
leading joints in data science and
artificial intelligence with real-time
industry experts making sure the program
covers the critical skills techniques
and hands-on experience with the
powerful image recognition tools to make
sure the learners are industry ready the
best part is all of this is for free of
cost
yes you heard me right and you can start
your image recognition and artificial
intelligence learning journey for free
of cost the course is 2 hours long and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course this allows you to learn
at your own pace anytime anywhere after
completing this course you will receive
a course completion certificate from
skillup this certificate can be shared
within your professional circle
the image recognition course focuses on
image processing and image recognition
techniques that facilitate object
detection
you will learn how to process data from
image files classify different types of
images and work with different neural
networks we will learn a brief overview
of artificial intelligence and image
recognition
then we will look into processing and
categorizing objects followed by that we
will deal with object segmentation later
we will focus on pattern identification
for the same
advancing we will deal with image
classification and localization
finally we will wind up the
certification program by understanding
the advanced image recognition
perspectives in real time by the end of
this course you will be an expert
artificial intelligence and image
recognition professional
so now you might be thinking who is
eligible to take this course well there
are no prerequisites to enroll to this
course each of you who has a zeal for
learning data science and artificial
intelligence can take up this course
irrespective of your experience so what
are you waiting for head straight to our
skill up page and enrich your image
recognition skills with leading
artificial intelligence tools and
techniques by enrolling in our free
course today
get closer to your dreams and what can
get better than a free certificate to
strengthen your profile certifications
bring you one step closer to backing the
opportunity and becoming an image
recognition and artificial intelligence
expert today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here